ils n'ont que 19 ans mais déjà une autre
vie à construire comme solène qui
vivaient en région parisienne il ya
encore quelques mois elle a bien tenté
d'expliquer à ses parents ce qu'elle
ressentait en vain un jour elle s'est
retrouvée dehors je suis une fille trans
et du coup je suis né dans un corps d'un
garçon et j'aimerais faire une
transition complète donc hormones
féminines et plus tard sur jeudi que
voilà j'étais pas dans ma peau genre
expliquer un peu les détaillants et tout
mais je leur ai pas dit j'aimerais faire
une transition pas fait je sais pas
comment il aurait pu le prendre parce
que avant j'étais le seul garçon ne m'a
patriotes à ryan qui a grandi entre le
sénégal et la france est lui aussi en
situation de rupture familiale il
n'avait pourtant jamais parlé
ouvertement de son homosexualité
mon père m'avait rush et quand
j'habitais encore s'élever à bordeaux et
a du coup j'ai dû venir à une entente
qui habite avait fort qui m'a aussi nez
dehors j'avais déjà d un truc quand
j'étais au sénégal même de mes propres
ça qu'ils amassent août et aider parce
que je faisais le ménage et enfin
j'aimais bien faire le ménage et enfin
j'aimais bien faire ce que les filles
faisait quoi si tu serais alors je sais
pas du tout c'est grâce à cette
fondation et à ses bénévoles que solène
et ryan dispose d'un toit et d'un
accompagnement mais les places sont
rares
on constate donc au niveau des du nombre
de demandes de demande qui ne faiblit
pas depuis donc les 18 ans d'existence
du refuge qu'il ya toujours des jeunes
qui se retrouvent exclus de leur famille
donc à cause de leur sexualité qui ne
rentrent pas dans la norme qui vient
effectivement de tous les milieux
sociaux que ça soit à limoux xiii aisés
comme les milieux
on pourrait dire un peu plus après les
milieux ruraux ils n'osent pas forcément
nous contacter donc c'est un petit peu
la différence ce sont principalement de
jeunes hommes qui sont accueillis par le
refuge leur lieu d'hébergement restent
confidentielles car les familles peuvent
parfois exercer des représailles